[موسيقى]
اتواجد في البصره القديمه حيث بيوت
الشناشيل هنا هذا طراز المعماري الذي نافس
الانهار والنخيل في الدلاله على الهويه
الجماليه لمدينه البصره التي تقع الى
الجنوبي من العراق هذه المدينه التي اصبح
اسمها ام الشناشير دعونا نتجول لنتعرف الى
تاريخ هذا المكان وما اصبح عليه اليوم
[موسيقى]
من يريد التعرف الى المدينه القديمه
والشناشيلها ما عليه سوى زياره متحف
الحسون فصاحبه واحد من الشخصيات القديمه
في البصره انشا هذا المتحف على طراز
وزخرفه الشناشير وعرض فيه مقتنياته
التراثيه
البسيطه بعدين الهوايه تطورت الى جميع قطع
قديمه يعني انتيكات للعوائل التابعه
للعوائل البصر القديمه
فحبيت اطوع هذا المشروع مالي فتحت همم
سويت متحف
في المتحف كانت ببالي اسوي متحف اختاريت
المنطقه القديمه اللي انت تتلائم
الطراز الانتيكات
يذكر لنا الشيخ صادق الحسون ان هذه
الشناشيل كانت بيوتا لوجهاء البصره
والشيوخها وانها بنيت بالاساس على ايدي
اليهود الذين سكنوها في السابق واصبحت
اليوم مزارا للسائحين
بهذه المنطقه يعني اعمارها تتجاوز 130 150
سنه
يشكلونها عيال البصره عيان البصره من
ضمنهم الشيخ خزعلي الكعبي
الشيء طالب النقيب
شعيان بيت البسام بيت المناصير هاي عوائل
البصره المعروفه يعني البصره يعني
لازم الكويت
الشناشيل او المشربيات والتي تعد عنصرا
معماريا امتازه ببروز خرافه يتضمن شرفا
خشبيه مزخرفه بمهاره واتقان ونوافذ من
الزجاج الملون وسطوح عاليه تاكلت هذه
الابنيه في السابق بفعل النسيان لكنها
تشهد مؤخرا حمله اعاده تاهيل ضخمه
بالتنسيق بين الحكومه المحليه للمحافظه
واليونسكوبي تنفذها اليونسكو بالتعاون مع
اا الحكومه العراقيه وزاره الثقافه ممثله
بالهيئه العامه للاثار والسياحه والتراث
في بغداد مع التعاون مع الحكومات المحليه
في محافظه البصره اذا هو مذكره تفاهم
وبرنامج عمل يسمى احياء مدينتي الموصل
والبصر القديمه
هل تحتفظ محله نظران في المدينه القديمه
في البصره باكبر عدد من بيوت الشناجر التي
تبلغ من العمر اكثر من 150 عاما ما جعلها
تكون وبجداره منطقه سياحيه ذات طابع تراثي
زينب المشاط صباح العربيه البصره